and thank you Goldman Vision even though
you're not actually here but that was
your voice thank you so much for the
intro and welcome guys to the official
38th the 39th episode if you count the
live stream episode of the weekly poll
we have officially crossed one year on
May 30th 2014 Rob contacted me and said
hey I want to do a podcast and I said I
got nothing better to do and we launched
the weekly poll and it started with
myself and Rob on the first episode and
we'll be playing a clip show that has
been on my channel but if you haven't
seen it you'll be seeing a show very
soon after this but guys I am Benny the
comic story and that is Rob from Marvel
explained I'm going by your original
name Apparently that is s from comic pop
that is f from it's super effective and
we're going to open this up classic
style with an old school role-played
battle now for those of you guys who
don't know how we started when we first
first did this there was a big debate as
to where we should put the show should
it go on Rob's channel should it go on
my channel should we rotate and so what
we decided was I would host a pre-show
in which we would roleplay two
characters so like for today I'm going
to be Bucky Barnes which is funny
because I know almost nothing about
Bucky and F is gonna be Tim Drake now
the reason why this works why I don't
have to know the character is our
additional hosts on the show are the
judges so basically the way this works f
is you're Tim Drake so I we'll open it
up with how we've met up and then you
just say what you do I pull out a bat
ring and I throw it whatever you want to
say and then the judges side if it's
viable for that character yeah and for
some reason I wasn't allowed to do this
which is
weird you want you want to be Bucky okay
fine I don't want to be buy you be buy
you be buy this is so much better you
actually know Bucky no you be Bucky
Barnes man you're you're Marvel
explained Comics explained
man I guess I guess we're going old
school we can just say Marvel explained
it's kind of go that I chose Tim Drake
because I was really stuck between Tim
Drake and Stephanie Brown and if I had
to role play Stephanie Brown it would
just be case of I'll mess everything up
right I kissed him drink okay so Rob Rob
since you since you're making a stink
you get I I made one C I make a stink no
you did you did you made a stink and now
now not only you going to do that but
that means I'm going to roll with music
for the background we're going to pull
out the Epic comic story and Story music
and I'm GNA DJ your battle okay here we
go all right guys so here we go bear in
mind at first it might be a little
louder than expected because I got to
reduce it but
okay okay here is a question we need to
ask though which version of okay the new
winter soldier version latest versions
on both characters okay that was going
to be my question about so here's the
opening here's the opening an incursion
has happened DC has met up with Marvel
and the Winter Soldier drops down in
front of Tim Drake as he's trying to
call up the Teen Titans to see what
they're doing okay which
Tim version it should be like Red Robin
or something oh yeah Tim Drake Red
Robin's in charge of the team Titans
still okay fair
enough oh this is the get just verion of
Tim Drake come on man you got to get on
it dude you got to you got to tell me
what he's going to do you got to do it
come on F
go
help Tim Drake opens up by saying Yeah
Tim Drake opens up by saying Help what's
what's Winter Soldier do Winter Soldier
wastes no time now since we're talking
about the Winter Soldier right now this
is Winter Soldier post Captain America
which means he still has access to Steve
Rogers Shield therefore he takes a
shield and punes it throws it at Red
Robin knocks him off his
ass okay okay I can I can work with this
since Tim Drake has been trained by
Batman and he's a gymnast he is able to
quickly backflip out of the way okay
fine then Bucky Barnes the Winter
Soldier since he has training both by
the United States government as a spy as
well as the Russians plus his enhanced
arm which is made of metal he runs up on
Tim Drake as fast as he can before Tim
Drake can finish his back flip and he
punches him in the chest and knocks him
to the ground
nice okay Tim Drake has the battle armor
that most of the bat family have that
whenever someone punches them it s of
like electrocutes them oh taser armor oh
I I also wanted to point out that the
chat is saying that everyone but Benny's
mics are a little quiet I I just rais it
I'm trying to fix it as they're doing
their thing so all right so we we were
at taser armor damn taser armor okay
well obviously Bucky Barnes would be
affected by that which arm did you use
yeah they're saying much my metal arm so
he didn't lose the ability to lose to
use his arm that arm's not
gone uh okay um okay fine the Bucky
Barnes is knocked knocked down to the
ground um I guess he stands up a little
bit and shakes it off so I okay I'll
give you I'll give you a second shot
since I got a second shot nice okay and
Tim Drake lunges in for a punch with his
left hand cuz I don't know why that was
so specific
but I like what's special about that
left hand there with his left hand okay
maybe maybe Tim Drake like jerks it with
his left hand I don't know it's like
stronger than his right who knows why
are we going there that's not how these
battles go yeah okay
so all right so Bucky Barnes has
stumbled back
um
okay Bucky Barnes jumps out of the way
grabs Captain America shield again and
lunges in for an attack using Shield to
block using the shield to block the
blows of Tim Drake and then starts like
this onslaught of pummeling on Tim Drake
and then eventually pulls out a gun and
shoots Tim Drake in the leg okay you
just had like six moves no I how are you
pushes a button that calls The Avengers
and then they show up and you know what
I will throw them off S since this is an
incursion as you were moving forward you
were stumbled because the planets began
to collide oh no oh my god well I guess
we know how this going to end
everybody's going to get blown
up Maybe not maybe a convergence will
take place and they can be
stupid why are we fighting hey bro let's
go and get some Starbucks cool shake
hands and they go and get Starbucks
because
they're and then Bucky Barnes drinks the
Starbucks and then when he's done
drinking the Starbucks he punches Tim
Drake again fight back on let's
go now he's energized by caffeine by
caffeine okay so where are where are we
in this fight EX you're in Starbucks now
and the world's Shad I don't know why
the Starbucks is still awake I mean
liive why why is Starbucks there we're
in the Starbucks in Manhattan and like
the world's going to Pieces so like
we're in the Starbucks which means we
have all kinds of stuff at our disposal
we have the machines they use to make
those espressos like we have the little
uh those little cakes that they have
that nobody ever buys because they're so
expensive like we've got all kinds of
stuff fight it was Bucky bonds Landing
in front of Tim Drake which means Tim
Drake still got all of his resources
available to him right yes okay Tim
Drake presses a button in his sleeve and
it calls aart and it brings all of his
little robot minions to him cuz he has
those apparently in thatal they were
there for like one frame but they exist
robot minions oh are they Nano or are
they just like little robot guys they're
robots that he programs to fight with it
was yeah it was it was a nanom machine
villain that he had to fight and he got
control of them gotcha oh I think ready
ET
Jal I finally read it
I regret
but that's not okay no no no okay that
is fair all right so in the death of
Captain America during that storyline uh
Bucky Barnes was operating with Nick
Fury if you guys remember when all that
happened when Sharon Carter shot Captain
America when crossb shot Captain America
Bucky Barnes is like is this what of
your plan and Nick Fury's like no
there's something else going on here now
because of that tie between Bucky Barnes
and Nick Fury Bucky Barnes contacts Nick
Fury and Nick Fury calls in an EMP that
WI out the robots of uh of Tim Drake so
now we have no robots you solar
beam see I know what I would do if I
could use pre New 52 Tim
Drake if we have incursions I think we
could use convergencies
if I if I can do can I just go ahead and
do this go for it I I I the judge s has
made it allowed okay then Tim Drake
calls in his friend Clarion the witch
boy and clar and claron turns into a
horle and begins beating on
Bucky okay fine if you can use
convergences I can use Secret
Wars oh okay okay if I can use Secret
Wars then that means we'd have to assume
that because Captain America on planet
Hulk is H is hunting for Bucky Barnes
Bucky Barnes exists in Planet Hulk and
so what does what does he do he contacts
the
Maestro
mro then you have to assume the mro
would help you
of course the mro okay let's say the mro
okay fine then he doesn't call him the
mro he calls him like Joe Fixit since
Joe fixit's working with C with Captain
Amer with Steve Roger so Joe fixed Hulk
comes in and now we've got Joe fixed
Hulk in the
equation okay I I think I think this
battle's gone long can we just say the
worlds explode and everyone just forms
converence War see this is why the
battle's ended because either we chose
characters where it like devolved into a
fist fight or we chose characters that
could like warp reality or call someone
who does here's the deal you've heard
how both of these guys have defended
their characters so for the course of
this episode the chat the evilest
villain in the entire world we need you
to decide did Bucky Barnes win with all
of his crazy Maestro stuff or did F win
for Tim Drake with their help from
claron you decide this time and we're
going to move to the next segment of our
special not really special show and for
the first try F that was an excellent
effort yeah did a good job considering F
had no idea what we were doing five
minutes ago let me stop you okay let me
let me stop everybody for a second all
right everyone shut up before we jump
before we jump into this new section
into this into this next section of the
podcast um I would like s and Fa to take
a second and join me in thanking Benny
because a lot of you guys out there in
the chat have no clue how busy like
Benny's like the hardest working man on
YouTube I swear to God like between the
channels that he runs and all the work
he's like the website was Benny like New
York ComiCon last year was bny Comic Con
this year is Benny like VidCon has been
like all that stuff is all Benny so so
just take a second and say thank you to
Benny thank you Benny for getting all
this [__] sorted out man because it's
been crazy absolutely thank you man well
thank you guys I
mean pleasure he really
is
yeah hold on we're breaking up like
crazy is it me is it your signal I got
nothing dropped on my end so I don't
think it's me
yeah no I don't think it's you I don't
think it's you at all I think
it's
me oops it's someone I think it's are
you downloading yes download I'm
sorry awesome I know how to shut I don't
know how to shut this thing off how do
you shut the Xbox one off Xbox off I
don't know how to shut shut
really Rob Rob just bought an Xbox One
guys yes I don't know how to I don't
know how to I don't know how to use okay
I like this one though Benny's ego got
too big and messed up the connection
that sounds about right okay thank you
guys though I mean we I I I I never
really thought about it like that but
thank you for mentioning that so yeah
but we're fine now that Rob turned off
his Xbox yeah we're a whole lot better
now my bad like I was I was downloading
the Halo uh Master Chief Collection
which apparently sucks so that sucks
which apparently
sucks
good run good run Rob good run all right
so okay U well the next thing I was
going to play is the year Montage
brought To Us by Goldman Vision it's
been on my channel if you've seen it if
you haven't been we're going to play the
year Montage of every single episode he
put together this awesome Montage okay
guys he did do we have Montage Music or
is that I think it's in there it's in
there yeah you're the all right here we
go quiet
you that's not the right one hold on
that's the right
one welcome to the weekly poll your
number one source for comab book
discussions I'm Benny from comic story
in that's your cute ever oh
okay what's going on what's going on
guys this is Rob I'm from uh Marvel
explain and this is David I don't have a
channel but I
[Laughter]
should and the brightest day and the
Blackest Night no evil shall Escape my
light let let those who worship Evil's
might beware my power Green Lantern's
light welcome to the weekly pool oh we
lost Dave again hi everybody I am s I'm
from a channel called TV Little House
youtube.com/ TV house from a far away
dimension of obscurity we should do the
entire podcast this way know you want to
give me Rob I'm just I'm just I'm just
going to say it all right learn how to
do Skype cuz no one can hear you
again this is is this too hammed up am I
this is my real voice we got to stay
pretty simple with it so while I do
think
that black and scary the episode when he
died but when morph would show up and
he's all sad and emo and he's like and
he's like I'll just turn into Jean Gray
and then hit on Wolverine and then why
do I care that the Midas Empire is back
oh you don't anybody else like
Wolverine's one of the few unkillable
characters that's kind of like what made
him into an interesting character hello
everybody and welcome to Marvel
explained my name is name is Rob what's
going on guys this is Benny from comic
storian and I'm so excited to be
here uh my name's Eris last name
konz um you look you guys wanted me to
do the Mario voice to open so but based
upon the fact that I heard it sucks I
don't want to see it cuz it's horrible
so I'm not sorry about that I'm I'm very
much happy about having seen that when
like the T-Rex showed up in the city
that was pretty awesome that that was
not that was awesome part of that movie
that was not very awesome I thought that
was a um Godzilla spin-off but okay um
that's that's what a lot of people
thought is that it was a Godzilla
spin-off which makes sense because you
know like it was it was a stupid idea
but due to our incursion we are merging
with England and we are having a battle
with the channel known as it's super
effective everyone welcome foun to the
show but now that we have Joel here um
[__] man we could talk about whatever
like yeah which we just were we we were
we were just kind of talking about
whatever oh yeah I like Van Halen Man
not van Hagar oh my God for a second I
thought you meant like vaning I'm I'm
full in for battle world and Secret Wars
and everything and he's gone what you
what are you doing Joel besides getting
shot dang it
Bob he wanted to take the scen
around I'm taking out the damn gang boss
no help from you guys
oh it's it's on that scene now oh my god
dude it was so
hilarious awesome they were awesome man
like okay like context for you guys when
we were talking when when we were
talking about the dinosaur in the city
me and S and Benny I think were talking
about uh the Lost World Jurassic
Park I don't know how how we got on that
but we did yeah probably because of the
upcoming movie yeah so I mean you guys
are doing exactly but I want to let them
know what we're doing I mean this this
is this is the year episode we're going
to kind of go through our favorite
moments what we thought about um we've
also had a lot of you guys submit a
bunch of videos um I know it was really
short notice we only got about five or
six I think but some amazing people have
submitted like their favorite moments in
the podcast and stuff like that so you
guys can see that also we play that near
the ending but I mean I guess I'll just
go ahead and say initially I think one
of the best moments my favorite moments
was honestly when we brought on S
because s went from s came on like hey
everybody I'm super awesome s and I'm
going to be the best thing on this
podcast ever and then he quickly
divulged into you know Screw you guys I
hate this dude it was it was so funny
because s was so reserved soell was like
like I love everything about comics and
Comics are the greatest thing ever now
it's like like this writer has no clue
what the hell they're doing and the
story was stupid like the whole Scott SN
I do have to say like when I first came
on the podcast I did like kind of have
in my head like yeah this guy's going to
be like yeah I love everything this
guy's going to be super judgmental and S
I thought was just going to love
everything and just be that guy it's
like yeah it's all great and then he
does one of my favorite things ever
where you can tell if we're talking
about something that he really hates
because he pulls this
face that seems like the S Guff like
like s's way of guffing people like like
when you're talking to someone and
they're not listening sounds like yeah
that's cool yeah all right man just like
that exactly yeah no I mean like I I'm
I'm I'm giving the floor I'm like no you
have an opinion share it I'm going to
share mine as well I louder and more
Furious I don't want to be like I don't
want to be like that guy who's like
who's like yeah totally absolutely
wrong I don't want to agree and then
jump into my opinion so I like you know
I concede your point but I also Express
that you you know I'm going to be
countering it but thank you very much
for mentioning that F oh yeah dude no
okay no no offense guys like s did make
the podcast a whole lot better like that
see that was a kicker like when I was
doing my interview with with Scott with
nerdsync you know he was I I like I just
went on this big like 20 minute story it
was like story time for 20 minutes and I
I just remember everything like how it
all got started and I was like me and
Benny needed a third guy like we needed
like a third guy that knew about comic
books because Dave was cool but Dave
only knew what he read and like the the
the handful of St that was and so he
wasn't like current with a lot of a lot
of the things and so when Dave you know
when we were looking for another guy
like I was going through YouTube and I
found I think it was I don't remember if
it was you or me but I think it was me
that found s maybe it was you but I
don't remember which one of us found us
but I remember the the the reason why
like we agreed to contact s is because
like I don't remember which one I found
it but I was for some reason watching
s's Channel and I was playing the game
Dark Souls 2 in my living room and I had
s's channel on like autoplay for like
the entirety of Dark Souls 2 so I
watched every on Sal Channel just like
while I'm getting killed in Dark Souls
and we got to the end of I'm like we
need to invite this guy because I know
everything about him
now thank you yeah um I love that
episode of nerd of that that podcast you
did because like you go into your career
and it's awesome and then you're like
and then you start just talking about
how great everyone who isn't on that
podcast was where you're like s's great
and Benny's great and F is great and man
they're just so great he like this is a
great
episode well it was it was it was it was
funny because like as as soon as we
brought you on and like when we got done
like me and bny talked as soon as you
were out and we're like we need to bring
him back like we need to have him back
and like yeah because like like I always
said you improved the show you did you
brought us brought in the the other
point of view we needed yeah Rob and I
just interrupted each other all day oh
yeah um I remember getting that in my
inbox like in the you know the thing
nobody checks YouTube messages and and
uh for whatever reason I checked it and
like only a I had only missed Rob's
inquiry like a couple of days as opposed
to like
months where uh but Comics explained
back then was like you know hey I like
your show or I like your channel you
should you should give us a call and I
was like yeah that sounds great
okay and I was excited to me because I I
like I like podcasting I like the the
the the format I never have an
opportunity to really like run one and I
never have an opportunity to really like
I don't I never have a focus you know so
this was a great opportunity like to
meet some really like-minded individuals
to work with some really awesome people
and to like talk about something that I
can talk about for more than like 10
minutes was nice that was a funny thing
because um because yeah like like I
think we brought you on the second time
and then we were like we're just going
to make this like we're just going to
bring like let's let's just bring him in
but it's funny looking at hindsight cuz
when we first watch you on you had like
800 Subs I did and then your Channel's
just like boom well I think I think when
we brought him on like you were at 6K
and I was at at 2K like we were all like
complete nobody's like matter of fact I
remember when you first contacted me Rob
you were like hey I'm trying to network
and trying to make some friends and I
when you first got me like I was like
like a thousand subs and I'm like yeah
sure why not how what what could go
wrong with podcasting year later Lally
nothing like apparently nothing can go
wrong it has only succeed it has only
helped everyone like it's been great um
and I and keeping this moving because
we'll go through each one everyone
else's favorite ones yeah but cuz I mean
personally for me whenever we find
someone that meshes well with us that's
like the big moment like the things I
like and I think the second biggest
moment was F because comic Drake was
doing a great job working with this but
comic Drake has the internet that like
ants use so it's like super slow so like
we were in like a bit of a bind because
we were like Dave had officially kind of
left at that point it was just a three
of us and we're like we we need that
fourth dynamic because and I was like
who do we go to and I remember
contacting a few people and I came
across your channel f and I'm like love
his stuff it'd be a great another
opinion to throw into here he'll
probably never talk to me and you got
back to me like within minutes like sure
sounds great what do I
do I always worry that I'm a bit creepy
because I like I always have my email
open in the moment it goes from 202 to
203 unre I'm like check and I reply
straight away um but no I I was excited
to come on cuz like I thought I was the
one of the only comic book YouTube
channels then I was like wait there's a
whole Community here what
yeah we were all just the other corner
of the house you were just your your
little world yeah I will admit I was
really really worried about coming on
cuz I can either be really really
hateful or really really positive and
there is no in between with me so I was
like do I work on a podcast but no it's
been a lot of fun it's been a lot of fun
and I'm happy that I actually get to
talk to people about doing YouTube now
cuz I was on my own for the longest time
yeah I think that's the worst part about
YouTube is like I mean Rob and I both
came together initially because we tried
the gaming channel and it's like this is
the most lonely and depressing
profession you could possibly no one
will talk to you everyone is mean in the
comments no one is constructive like
everyone is out to just ruin you and you
can't make friends even if your life
depended on it yeah and like Rob came to
me and he's like we should like Network
together I'm like sounds like a great
plan man cuz my experience in the gaming
world was not a good one I got to say
like just because like while we're on
that subject like this has been like
when it comes to expectations in YouTube
like be being a comic book YouTuber and
being part of this has been one of the
most positive experiences on the
internet for me like number one we're
working with really positive people I
mean like we may be like I might be an
incredibly negative person every once in
a while but like uh the fact is like we
like we work really well together we
really like working with each other
there's no like There's No Nonsense
involved where we're like you know where
we hate each other or where we're like
trying to outdo each other in a
non-friendly way you know Benny and Rob
that that's their that's their business
that's that's what we do you know oh Rob
I'm beating you again well I'll just
kill you in your sleep
and wow Rob never went to that
extreme yeah that's that was never told
to me in private but
uh let's just say New York ComicCon was
a very different experience for me as
opposed to you guys but uh oh
in addition to that I think also the
community itself has been incredibly
positive
like there's never been I think a more
like welcoming understanding and just
overall positive Community than this one
like th those like the chat while we may
you know while they themselves might
portray them as like Monsters put
monsters yeah according to the Twitter
uh drawing
contest but uh but they're they're like
my they're like the fifth member of the
show and like I love them it's great
yeah it's and you know what I go ahead
Rob it's F go ahead man I was just gonna
say because people are commenting on
other people I do want to make it clear
we do have the the B team of the weekly
poll the the swap in West Coast Avengers
kind of guys you know we do West Coast
Avengers that's totally true Avengers
yes and and and I mean and they're all
great too don't get me wrong like I'm I
I have nothing against Sammy Joel both
of them rotate in quite frequently at
this point they become
like rotating regular members Drake
intends on coming back and he'll be
another rotating member like everyone
who is a part of this has been great all
of our guests have been great just the
reason I brought up Salam f is because
when you find that guy that those guys
that just click consecutively and they
like you're going to be able to make a
show without a problem and you're going
to be able to have everyone show up
without an issue and we all agree
disagree but in a friendly manner That's
Unique like every I mean I'm pretty sure
Joel Sammy or even Drake would easily be
able to fill any one of these spots but
the fact that the four of us do this so
well is is what I liked when you guys
came on so we're
awesome this is one of the few times we
can all be like yeah we're all we're
pretty damn everyone pat yourself on the
back it's like like a two-minute
two-minute like statement of how awesome
we are yeah hey guys aren't we just so
great it's like it's like uh at the end
of New York Comic Con when Rob was just
like Rob just took it hey guys can we
just take a second I just want you guys
to know this is like this like the best
day ever like you guys are just so great
is just so great yeah well it like it
didn't feel great at the end of the
first day [__] no I didn't mean the
first day like it was at the end of the
at the end of the The Experience let me
tell you guys in the chat like let me
okay let me let me tell you guys let me
tell you guys the infamous newk ComiCon
let's let's sit down let's sit down chat
let's Vape it up VAP let's Vape let's
let's sit down and let's tell a story
let's uh let's stop uh let's pull over
and try and find a place that has Vape
once upon a time there there see like
there was there used to be this evil Rob
way back when
you know like last year in like October
like October there was there was a there
was a bad rob you know there was an evil
Rob and and I made that evil Rob go away
but
um man I we rolled in a New York ComiCon
and I was excited as hell I was like yes
I'm so psyched for this and then at the
end of the day like my feet hurt I had
no ecigarette juice and I was I was like
man like this [__] sucks yeah but it
was that New York ComiCon was
interesting cuz we all get to work with
each other first for the first time for
more than like a 2our discussion like we
we were pretty much staying like an hour
like not even like 10 minutes away from
South house we were all hanging out
nonstop and it's when you really get to
learn everyone and I am a consistently
going 90 miles an hour person and Rob
real like eye opener for everybody yeah
and Rob really is a super chill guy who
Vapes all day and S really is like the
dad of everyone yeah okay okay okay not
only that not only that all right check
this out so so I land in the airport for
um land I what was it where where do we
land where do we meet B New York New
York yeah it was New York airport nework
no okay yeah so Oh you mean like what
hotel did you stay in no no no like when
me and Benny met at like our connecting
flight that took us to to New York I
don't remember where that was but
wherever it was like it was in
Pennsylvania or something like that
anyway so I call Benny and I'm like hey
man I'm in the airport where he at he's
like well I'm down here and so he comes
he he's like I'll meet you wherever and
so he comes walking up dude this dude
shows up this sc's shoulders like that
wide
he's toing like 15 bags of stuff and I
did not have you had you had dude you
had so many bags of stuff I had a
backpack and a suitcase that's what I
always travel with okay you had you had
a whole bunch of stuff but um but anyway
so so he comes he comes walking up and
I'm like all right dude what's going on
you know we greet and we're like hey
what's up you know and so I was like I
don't know about you but I'm hungry he's
like yeah I'm hungry too we get some
breakfast he's like dude I don't know
about you man but I'm starting this
morning off with a drink man it's like
9:00 in the morning and he gets like a
bloody married I like dude are you are
you okay okay was the flight that bad
drinking alcohol 9 see this is why I
think it's going to be interesting when
you guys like meet me cuz you'll realize
like this hyper creative thing just
isn't put on I'm always like drawing or
something and it gets annoying like even
for me that's just it that's what we
realized when we all finally met up like
these aren't acts we put on this is us
like I mean I remember I remember the
end of the first day Rob was about to
strangle me because I got to the con and
I'm like business business business we
got to talk people makes the connections
and Rob is like screw that I'm sitting
the hell down I haven't had Vape all day
and I remember at the end of the day
Rob's about to strangle me I'm about to
strangle Rob and s's just like we're
gonna find you goddamn babe and we're
gonna end this and we're gonna get food
dude okay so so that's the other thing
so so me and Bennie are at the hotel
like or Me by and Dave are at the hotel
we're waiting on S and s's like hey guys
I'll be there in a few minutes so we're
like okay so we get this knock on knock
on the on the hotel room door cuz I'm in
Benny's hotel room at this point like we
answer the door and there's like this 10
foot tall dude
and he is like hey what's going on guys
and we're just like what the hell man
how need you get
tall I mean and for the record guys
we're doing New York ComiCon again all
of us will be there including F this
time F can't wait that like as much much
we we do talk about how like you know
New York ComiCon was kind of like a
ridiculous experience overall number one
I had blast at the end of yeah like all
distilled down like it was really cool
and number two I can't wait for this
October for conom and and this time I
mean when we first did this we were all
still really minor channels and stuff
like that but I think we're actually
going to like form an actual Meetup
Meetup this time hey still met people
which was really awesome like that was
that was uh that was mind-bending like
people like we were waiting we were at
the corner we were like on the top of
the stairs like in the entryway for the
Javits and we were hanging out I
remember who we were waiting for but we
were peret like that's the thing with
New York Comic you go with more than two
people you will always be perpetually
waiting for someone yeah and so at this
point a few of us were like stand
standing there waiting for somebody and
people just kept coming up and being
like Oh my God it's Marvel explain holy
crap were you comic storian didn't it
didn't hurt that comic storian was
wearing a shirt with his own face that's
true yeah but the the best part was the
first guy that recognized us like are
you comic storian I flown all the way
from like overseas and I just it's
amazing that I get to meet you and I'm
just sitting there like really like and
he's like can you do the voice and I'm
like
like I'm talking this is my voice like
no no the voice for the videos like
hello supposed to do I had like this
weird moment at uh London MCM this past
weekend um where Nella and I did a panel
together uh Nella is another UK YouTuber
and no it's like noodles
not you say Nella I'm not thinking
noodles buddy
[Laughter]
her cosplay is tassels that's exactly
what I was thinking man walk around with
tassels on her Bo she's the most family
friendly Channel ever that's she really
spectacular wow um but we did a panel
together expecting uh maybe a few people
turn up we'll just do a Q&A of the
people that turn up there were people
standing outside trying to get in as the
panel was going on all the seats were
taken I was like oh my God they're not
M&M's the subscribers are real people
that that was that was probably the most
rewarding part of New York ComicCon was
like randomly walking around like there
was there was one dude named Brent and
I'll never forget this like it was this
guy named Brent I think and um it was me
and S hanging out we were it was and
okay one of the worst Parts was we
didn't even realize about like the art
the whole artist alley like the writers
and everything like that whole other
section oh yeah until like the second
day until like the end of the second day
and we were like oh my God that was the
end of the second day and I was getting
autographs and stuff and then I just got
bored and left and I was like I'm go
down
elsewhere I'm tired but um that's right
and we were like hey Rob you know CH
Chris claremont's over
there what what but um but no it was it
was an incredibly rewarding thing to
just kind of be chilling there but but
yeah like like Brent walked like me and
S were hanging out and Brent walked up
and he was like he's like you're your
Marvel explain and I was like yeah I was
like yeah it's me and and uh and TV
because it was TV little house at the
time it was T and um and like he was he
was talking to us he's like yeah man
like I I love comics and like I'm
getting my girlfriend into comics and
like my girlfriend is you know reading
this you know and it's crazy like you
know we watch your videos all the time
and it was just it was it was crazy to
to be there and to have you guys like
walking up to us and saying like you
guys like we love your content you guys
are amazing like that is that that was
probably the most humbling experience
I've ever had you know because it's huh
no go ahead go ahead I'll it's one thing
like I mean when like making videos and
putting them out there on YouTube like
you know other people are watching it
like you know that somebody's watching
on the way that class you know that
somebody's probably watching it while
they're in class you know people are
watching it at work people are watching
like all people from all walks of life
are watching your videos but like it
makes it more concrete when somebody
walks up to you and they're like I watch
your videos and I love your content it's
just like yeah wow that was that like
similarly when when Benny was sharing a
couple of the viewer response videos
with us when we were going over this
episode I was like wow like just it made
it a lot more real and like you said
earlier like it is kind of a solitary
experience like you make something you
shoot it and then you just sit in a room
and you cut it and you render it and you
add gravity and then you throw it out
there and then and you hope to God
they're nice yeah and then words come
out that say like that you're an ahale
you're like a [__] and you know you're
just like okay well you know try try
again later like but like to see people
come up to you and also to like make
videos that say like hey man I like
something you did
like yeah I agree with you 100% that
that's the most incredible part about
all of this cuz like I said Rob and I
Rob and I were doing YouTube longer than
the comic book thing and both of us
dealt with the the solid like how with
just the mean and nasty world of gaming
content and trying to try to make your
way into gaming content with five
kajillion other people trying to do the
exact same thing you are and just not
being able to do that and to go into
this comic book world and to have the
most amazing Community I've ever seen
ever like to like At first the community
was cool and I'm like oh people are
starting to recognize our names that's
pretty cool you know people enjoy the
videos they like they like me doing the
stupid voices or acting like I'm Batman
or something like that or you know they
like f opinion on on Starfire I think
that's one of your best better
performing ones the sexuality of
Starfire or they love to see it's just
because it's got boobs in the
thumbnail or or like you know they love
to see Sal rip on his friends and and
them go nuts or or they just love to
hear Rob vaping and and talking about a
comic book for 40 minutes like this is
back in those days I mean that like you
said it's humbling because you're like
oh that's cool they enjoy her stuff but
I just went like I think the biggest
realization that this has gotten a lot
bigger than than any of us have even
thought it had gotten to cuz New York
ComiCon was cool we met some really cool
people but we also made it very public
we were going when I went to the
Singapore thing and I told the story
about what happened with the Singapore
thing in the last post show but to to go
to a foreign country and people go out
of their way to show up where you're
just going to go hang out for 30 minutes
that was like there's people who
actually just want to come and meet me
like why I'm just a guy who reads a
story yeah that's that's the crazy
that's the crazy thing of it all like
like we're just guy who are like here's
this one thing that we love and we're
going to talk about it on YouTube for
like 5 minutes all the way up to like 40
minutes and then you guys are like you
guys are amazing yeah and this is not
expected at all like we were just we're
g to chat about some Comics maybe we'll
we'll get a small fan base but like none
of this yeah fan bases were the last
thing that I even considered I'll tell
you let let F
Sor I think that was like the weirdest
part for me because when I started my
channel I really just had no focus at to
I was doing anime and comics and video
games and maybe one we could talk about
rupal's drag race
um how
that well the rupal's drag race videos
don't exist anymore so
that um but no that's the weird thing
for me because like especially getting a
bit deep here especially as a gay person
on YouTube in like a mostly straight
male Domin area I expected I'll never do
well I'll never do well and but the only
thing that's negative thing that's
really come of me being gay is that I'm
constantly reminded of my sexuality and
honestly I'm really forgetful so it's so
it's good to have that reminder every so
often yeah I mean but I mean and that
this whole thing has just been
incredible and like the last I went to
Denver Comic Con and people were just
recognizing me walking around and no I
only walked with my own shirt on for
like half the
trip yeah no I I did do that
legitimately though cuz I was trying to
talk to creators and stuff and it's
better when you have like some kind of
like you know work shirt kind of a
situation like this is me you know
that's that's a big thing back when we
used to do a lot more Creator interviews
on TV little housec comic pop like not
dressing like dressing a little bit more
like a Creator or like a professional
really helps like talking to them like
as opposed to just wearing like your
biggest Spider-Man shirt ever and being
like hey you you're Ron Garney like
it really helps to like present yourself
as best possible way yeah but no and and
and and the the biggest moment and this
and I think this was kind of like the
turning point it literally was because
going to conventions and everything
people are are looking for you they're
they're trying to find you you know
going to even to Singapore they they I
mentioned I was there I was going out
into town the other week uh last week
and I went to the local GameStop just to
buy a game and I'm literally in my gym
cloth so I got like this oversized
hoodie I got some gym things my hair is
nowhere near as beautiful it is right
now you know sure and I had a random guy
be like are you on YouTube are you the
comic storian and I'm like uh yeah
like that happened to me before I was
literally walking around a supermarket
in town and then I came home and on my
Facebook page I had a message saying hey
were you in tesos just now because I
think I saw you I was that kid in the
school uniform and I was like I need to
move I had a comment like that the other
day I had a kind leave a comment like
three ago the comment goes I think I
know you comic storan and then a
followup yes I do know you and then a
followup I'm near you and I'm like oh
that's how that's how people that's how
like celebrities get murdered like
that's how John Lin got
shot I don't
know but I think I think to close out
this segment of what we're talking about
here and I think we all agree on this
like all of this is is like you guys I
mean you guys are awesome and you thank
us for our content you think it for
everything we do but the fact is this
entire Community everything that's come
out of this isn't is all because of you
guys not us like we could I could make
videos all day but if none of you
enjoyed it or watched it or commented it
wouldn't matter it wouldn't go anywhere
and it's because of you guys that
everything keeps growing like this it's
because of you guys that we came
together made the weekly poll we made
the website we tried to make the forums
or we got the Facebook by the way there
is a Facebook for those of you guys not
tracking it facebook.com backthe the
weekly poll and then there's the Twitter
at weekly poll you should probably
follow those if you like everything we
do but yeah everyone should
follow it is are you are you like it
right now F
no um yeah no it's it's crazy you know I
guess to to kind of capitalize on on
what Benny said here you know it's it's
to look back at the last year you know
and to see how much everything's grown
you know and to because you know it's
it's I don't know I mean it's it's it's
just kind of funny you know because like
a year ago I was working a regular job
and now I'm doing this you know and a
year ago Benny had his gaming channel
and he was out of the military now he's
doing this you know a year ago s was
doing s was doing the same thing so I
was
unemployed out for S we're trying to get
S to where he doesn't come home Angry
and yell at us but but s you know s was
cranking out his and it's it's just it's
funny to see how it all comes together
how it all just sort of plays out you
know and and everything results into
where it is now and that's you know so
yeah so so so thank you so much to you
guys I mean for all of you guys who have
been around since the beginning those of
you guys who just showed up today you
know like thanks all of you guys for for
all your support because it's uh without
it this would not be what it is now it
would be very it would be a lonely sad
world yes it would
be so quit your job be one of them and
if somebody wants to know what we call
the weekly pull fans I'm going with the
pullers but yeah I don't I say I say we
just call in the chat like the chat the
chat like the chat that is that is the
name you guys by the way hope sami's
still watching because she has to pick
the winner and shoot me over on Skype or
Twitter to let me know what it is oh
yeah no pressure or anything
Sammy but it has to be the chat with a
little French accent Over the Sea so
it's the
shat you whisper it yeah but like cat
next uh next month we're going to be
launching the weekly poll's first
perfume line and F will be on the
commercial the shot the
sh coming soon being a wind machine and
a long scarf and the
hair I mean dude that that would be like
that'd be the best commercial ever like
like I would so dude okay okay so
imagine imagine that commercial and like
imagine a voice comes on like imagine
you're in the comic book
store reading through your favorite
issue of Spider-Man when
suddenly a beautiful woman Taps you on
the
shoulder excuse me she
says you're a little shocked to see this
you turn around because you're a comic
book fan and a woman's talking to you
it's
weird and she says I can't help but
notice you
smell like
sh you smell you smell like
[__] for the record I I have yet to see
Sammy talk but everyone's talking to
Sammy so I don't know what's going on in
the chat I don't know what's going on in
the chat either but talking to about a
sword and I don't I don't see Sammy
talking she talking oh is she there
she's there yeah yeah she's talking to
him she's talking part of this
commercial I could be that man that's in
the comic store and I could be that
woman so I'm both characters I a New
York ComiCon one of the days you do that
that cross cosplay where you're half
woman half man for a day it's called
crossplay
crossplay No crossplay is when I
cosplayed Harley Quinn and showed my
nipples to yayahan by accident how' that
work out for you wow oh I placed in the
competition actually so
nice that's a lesson to all you would be
cosplayers for the record um and we're
going to put this one a fast but
apparently the what we've been saying is
vagina in French so maybe we should not
call the first no we Haven well I mean
let's let's consult let's consult Google
translate oh yeah cuz that's very
reliable Universal source for all
languages wait Benny why don't you just
ask your wife isn't doesn't she she's in
the shower and that'd be a really weird
first year episode we're going to the
shower to talk to my
wife yeah that would be weird I'm just
so used to how just sat there behind you
everyone is I've got comments of it's
weird without her playing a game all
right guys so what we did um U and we'll
get back to talk about this in a minute
but uh what we did was I sent and this
was literally last second so um I sent
out a tweet open-ended hey anybody if
you can make a quick video we'll play it
in the episode um keep in mind some of
these people are doing it off their
phones they have low quality so it might
be lower um but we but they were kind
enough to give us their thoughts and
their opinions on the show so I'm going
to kind of go through these things one
at a time we also I asked every one of
our previous guests and this was short
notice so not all of them got back to us
in time uh we don't have errors we don't
have Mr Sunday movies um but I did ask a
lot of the old guests to kind of submit
some kind of something also what they
like about the weekly poll so we're
going to play through those real quick
and uh everyone what are you giggling
about F what are you giggling about
someone posted Le pullers and then if it
does mean what they're saying yeah I saw
that it does it doesn't like like vagina
does not like Shat does not mean vagina
in French like Google that guy that guy
trolled us good he trolled the entire
weekly
pull all right guys and on that note I'm
going to start with these videos um I'll
open up with the uh the two guys that um
that submitted the the the viewers the
fans who watch this stuff um and then
we'll go into the uh the ex co-host that
we've all fired and they've just not
found out on the
show although there was a good idea real
quick there someone did say a good idea
we should just have a second podcast
that contains all of the West Coast
versions so Drake Sammy
Tiffany I mean that'd be cool I mean I
like is Tiffany like yes or no she's
back there like no she's like yeah she's
like I'm in oh by the way by the way you
guys like before you get into this for
all of you guys who are curious in the
chat yes Tiffany is short and yes
Tiffany is like the most hyperactive
human being in existence like oh my god
dude she like just bounces around and
like always moving like standing on her
tippy toes it's it's crazy like you guys
think I'm wired see her in real life
like the kicker is SS like Godzilla just
chilling there like go and she's like
and he's like all right and she's back
let's go yeah gets things done is it
like they have the same amount of energy
but like the energy forel has to be
distributed amongst a
giant it's just like a small body yeah
pretty much all right so we're going to
play some of these videos guys um and uh
we'll be talking to you in a minute
greetings to everyone at the weekly pool
from swadding Co in England my name is
Paul Jones or swaty on the weekly pool
site the weekly pool has been a part of
my most SE viewing list for the last
several months it's been a great
resource of information and me back into
reading comics for the first time since
the 198
giving away my age a bit there uh both
my daughter and I are regular view uh
visitors to our local comic book store
and we're doing our bit to support the
industry we love the stuff that you guys
do
um keep producing the high quality beds
the humor is great really makes me laugh
um and a happy birthday to the weekly
pool and many more years to come we out
peace
[Music]
this is Josh here and I'm in my mid-30s
and I was really into Comics as a
teenager and laid them down in the late
90s and uh because of the weekly pool
and because of your individual channels
I've been able to get back in the no and
I want to say thank you and uh I really
enjoy the humor in the weekly pool I
remember one segment we spent a whole
segment talking about what haggus was
with f and and Rob going back and forth
so I'm still waiting for haggas play
thank you hey guys congrats on a year of
the weekly pull that is 365 days I hope
you knew that anyway just wanted to say
that I think my favorite moment of just
the podcast in general is whenever fa is
interrupted and uh he just is not
allowed to speak it's a it's pretty
funny anyway congrats again hey guys
this is Comic Drake and I want to give a
huge super special awesome
congratulations to the weekly pull
podcast for reaching one whole year that
is quite an accomplishment the weekly
poll means a lot to me not because it
helped kind of Kickstart My comic book
career over on comic Drake Shameless
self-promotion aside but also I've made
a lot of great friends I mean Benny Rob
South F you weren't on when I was on so
I'm sorry I wish I could know you better
but you guys are some of the most
awesome friends that I have on YouTube
and I never would have been able to do
it if you guys hadn't invited me on the
podcast I'm so happy and so grateful
that I can call you guys except for f
because I don't know you well please add
me on Skype or something I can call you
guys my friends and it means so much so
yeah a little little sappy
congratulations guys I love
you hey there everyone it's your old pal
Joel of the comic book has podcast
Network and frequent guest on the weekly
pull podcast I'm here with a very
special message for Benny Rob S F and
everyone else in the extended weekly
pull Network here I'm thanking them and
giving a big old congrats for one year
of great work you guys run a hell of a
show and I know it's a hell of a show
cuz I've been on it quite a few times
and I also know you're just standup
dudes total aces in my book and just you
know great guys because I mean hey you
had me on for one episode then you kept
asking me back which goes to show just
how forgiving you are personally don't
think I'm that great I wouldn't I
wouldn't have asked myself back if I was
you guys but uh yeah weekly pool it's a
hell of a show how good is it it's a
show that even if I wasn't on it as
often as I was I would totally watch it
the community is great and wonderful uh
here's to uh your year anniversary
here's to many many more years down the
line of great entertainment you're going
to be delivering to everyone uh laim
vivaa weekly poll my favorite thing
about the weekly poll definitely has to
be how every everybody just respects
each other and even if they have
different opinions they're still buddies
you know also haggus
explained all right there we go and we
are back on the main thing so what I
mean you guys said you hadn't seen all
of those so I mean dude I think like
Joel's video it like the way it started
out it looked like something out of
scared straight
like dude Scared Straight is like it's I
don't know if you guys ever watched
scared straight but it was it was a
hilarious show back in the day okay love
watching that and I Didn't Know I Was
Pregnant side by side because those two
are just American reality TV gold yes I
don't know if you really wanted to see
like American reality TV you should
watch what was that Honey Boo Boo oh no
like it's like as American as it get
no so what did you guys think of all
those things I mean there such a nice
words from everyone everyone who's been
on everyone who's been a part of this
everyone who's just enjoying it I mean
and I loved how like three of them made
mention of haggus explained and like
them
made ha explained like like that's you
know what I'm going to have to like
explain that just so Rand and people
like what is this is the comic book
material it's like yes I know but still
like yeah well well you know what's
funny is Sammy doesn't isn't aware of
this but that last frame here I'll go to
that frame real quick uh yeah you got to
see that last frame on her
video that is totally going to get
turned into a meme this one right here
I'm I'm going to click to it real fast
it's going to get turned into a meme and
it's going to be epic on a live stream
definitely is yeah see this one this
right here totally getting memed Sammy
you can't do that and not get
memed I love how in the chat like oh
no
be so yeah no totally I'm sorry you
brought that on yourself that is going
to be so
MD it's just explained
explained if you ever do haggus explain
you need to use that as a thumbnail
that's the that's the cover that is so
getting like that's so going to be the
thumbnail if I ever
explain um no but see that's what we
were talking about guys like like I mean
I don't know about you guys maybe it's
just like a concept of preconceived
notions but I always imagined you know
before like I met with people before
people started send me messages saying
like I'm this years old you know I'm
whatever this ages I always assumed they
were younger like they were around my
age maybe within a few years of me or
maybe all the way down to like 15 or 16
years old it's funny getting a message
from a a man who's who's like seen some
stuff you know who's been around for a
while you know and mean I don't know how
I don't want to say he's old but like
you know to get a message from like from
an older individual and um and and hear
them say like I read Comics a lot when I
was younger and and I you know I get
back into them again you know I go and
see them I go and get them with my
family we watch your videos and and
that's that's like that's
crazy it's it's amazing no I agree with
that because it's it's so shocking to
see like that like just the range of
people who actually are into the show
and into into the comic books because
I've met like little kids who who are in
totally into it and they just love just
chatting and they can't hold a
conversation
and then to see someone older who's
without calling him old um who's into it
just shows like how far comic books can
bring like a community together how big
of a range is we're not just the Call of
Duty kids and we're not see I'm gonna
get a bunch of hate for that comment
just the Call of Duty kid are they still
like we're not just a whole bunch of
like Shriners in an old Club you know
that's true but then like at the same
time um I discovered cuz for the longest
time I've just been thinking you most of
my audience definitely over 18 you
demographic says they are that's
obviously accurate so I've just been
doing my thing okay if if
you like those of you in the chat if you
guys don't care just like post your age
just like throw your age in there and
say hell they're already doing that
they're already doing that I just realiz
that it's it's funny how it's a trend
because one person will be like I'm 15
years old and it's just like yep old man
Hogan is 32 I love the name to go with
that age old man Hogan at London Expo I
swear to God I met a whole bunch of
people and literally about four of them
had to have been over the age of 18 and
it was a bit like I talk about sex and
sexuality to Children I'm so
uncomfortable right
now yeah we had that happen one time we
did a live show at a local convention
and like there was a there was a a kid
there with his mom who is number one
what an awesome kid and number two what
an awesome mom cuz we did like of live
back issues and I didn't make any
attempt to censor it in any way
and like they both came up to us and
we're like hey like thank you so much
for what you do and blah blah blah and
I'm like you're
nine uh that said like you're awesome
but like you're like Mom you're cool
with this like and she was she brought
him there to meet us I was like wow like
that's really cool and and it makes me
feel really
irresponsible well no I mean it's it's
well honestly that that's why I keep
myself censored on our Channel and we
put up big warnings on like the the
worst show which is funny whenever I do
meet a kid it's like oh I loved your
Deadpool video where he Mass murdered
everyone in the entire world
and okay you don't censor anything on my
channel uh I I don't I don't bother
censoring anything because I swear a lot
but like I'm I'm from the UK like we do
it here like I don't realize like I
still was surprised about how many words
Americans think say a swear words and
then I'm like no that that's just a word
one of your one of your conversation
curses biggest cardinal
sins um the older gentleman that we've
been all saying we didn't want to say
how old he was he actually in the chat
he's and he says he's only 50 so it's
okay we're good thank you so much for
making that video man that's awesome I
didn't I mean I didn't okay dude I
didn't want to be like like the old guy
that sent that video in like that guy's
amazing you just say the
dude I don't want to say the old
guy Rob started that one then of course
I'm like well we got back into the same
problem we had with Sammy how old is she
oh God that was a hilarious thing like
how old how old is Sammy because it was
old do you think she is hold on hold you
know what let let's do that next let's
do that and fast I'm going to go first
let's go with the almost awkward moments
that have come out of the weekly Poll
for us yes there we go the I I would say
the first real awkward one and this is
this is I think we Sal you had just come
on the show the first one that I can
think of was when Dave had just had a
surgery and he's laying back his
microphone is down by his C on his tummy
but yeah was it was on something but
either way in order to hold it steady
his arms were constantly moving and
somebody started the trend in the chat
while we're going the guy guy in the
corner is jacking it and that started a
whole Trend all by itself God I I I
really like I I'm I'm very much like
even though I'm very in articulate I I'm
very much all about words and I love
like the the the visualization of
language and stuff like that so for me
when that guy wrote that it really for
me like the image that came out my mind
was a was a crowd of people watching the
show and one guy in the back going dude
in the back is jacking it that's really
what it looked like that's ex and and
then that became that was like the
predecessor to haggus explained like
literally every other episode was like
gu's jacking it yeah that that that was
like that was that was yeah before hagas
explained up until Dave was like gone
because Dave went back to yeah oh he
went back to work I mean he for all you
guys who asked forever Dave S came on
Dave left because Dave went back to work
that was basically it and Dave decided
he didn't have time to arrive at the
scheduled hours for the podcast and that
was it yeah um but once Dave left the
guy Jack and it went away it was funny
though that was my first awkward moment
we even got it on when you guys appeared
on an episode of back issues during the
New York Comic-Con week like Dave was on
the show and there's a comment I think
it's still there that says like guy in
the Corner's
jacket I'm like he's sitting right in
front of you you can tell he's not
jagging
it I mean what about you Rob what was
the first awkward moment that you
remember man the first Awkward Moment
was f d when F first came on I was like
I was like all right like I've I've got
a lesbian sister and so like I
understand like I can I can with within
like a reasonable way like within a
reasonable range tell if a person's gay
because like hang out with her you hang
out with gay people and I was like like
I think this guy's gay but I didn't want
to like say anything cuz one it didn't
really matter but two like I felt like
it would have made like this comfortable
situation and then and then you were
just like you're just like bam I'm gay
and I was like elephant out of the room
I I I remember that actually before you
before you you comment on this F I
remember that because I brought you in
and he was like like I remember Rob
calling me he's like hey is f gay and
I'm like I'm pretty sure he is do you
want to ask well no every's like no no
no no we're not gonna ask We're not
gonna ask We're not gonna ask maybe
maybe he'll just tell us and then you
out of the blue like we like the
pre-show or something you're just like
yeah so as a gay man like yeah I was I
was like okay but the thing is I'm not
just gay I'm a huge weirdo as well so
can't well it's I mean it's it's it's
man it's it's funny did I ever tell you
guys a story about the whole like 21st
birthday drag show thing yes okay one
my do what one of my favor yes that was
that was that was like my introduction
to like the gay community and I and I
will say this man like the folks at that
knew how to party like it was it was fun
as hell they knew what they were doing
but no it was it was just a funny thing
to me because I was I was like I mean I
didn't want to like throw it out there
and like offend you if you weren't but I
also didn't want to say anything in Cas
you I'm just really feminine why would
you say that I me the other thing is is
it's not like you walk up to a person
and say hey like are you gay it's like
it's like walking up to like a to like a
large woman and being like so when are
you what do you do like what the [__] is
your problem yeah I have to say like the
one thing that you can say to me like
that will get me off on a rant that's
like what the [__] is wrong with you is
to say to someone are you gay cuz I will
rant about that it's like a stupidly
expend yeah it's a thing I mean honestly
we're all friends but like especially
when you first came on we weren't on a
level where we just chat about anything
with you like you were still the
newcomer to the show so we didn't want
to make any kind of weird moments you
know by the way what underwear do you
wear you know I kept the weird Under
Wraps back then I seemed like a normal
human being um and then opened my mouth
uh right but yeah
that no go ahead it's fine I was to say
s what is your first Awkward Moment on
the show that's happened out of this I
know man like that's actually a
fantastic question that I cannot think
of right now uh I mean like sometimes I
I think we always do as a team come up
with a good awkward moment at least
every other episode where there's a
moment where we're
like we probably shouldn't have said
that um but yeah no I I I I don't feel
like there are any too there are too
many moments where we're like where it
was really that bad uh I love That Jag
inut story though that's my favorite
yeah F I mean you you're the newcomer
have you had any severe moments that
have been awkward that since you've been
on here well let me get on my list here
um besides the whole conversation about
freaking perfect that was awesome um
there have been a lot I'm not going to
lie I'm just an awkward person though so
I'm aware that cause most of them um I
have to say like most of them happen
pre-show or just in the chat like during
the week
um turning up in Drag and then no F no
is definitely um do we explain that
story like funny it was funny as hell is
what it was okay so for you guys know if
some of you follow the Twitter battle
between me and Fon be one of the
pre-shows about hair and Fs threw out
there that oh fine I'm going to beat you
I'm going to show up and dress now what
F says is because we normally pre-show
it like 30 minutes prior but we were
having an issue there was like a
connection issue or something along
those lines I couldn't remember what it
was so we didn't get to show up early
now F said he was going to show up make
everyone go what and then go change but
it was like five minutes before the show
F hadn't shown up yet and like I and I
was sitting to the other guys I'm like I
hope he's not late because he's getting
in the drag and in the honest reason the
reason was I didn't know how the
audience would take it like like what
would they say what would they do and
I'm like cuz audience is very divided we
have a bunch of kids we have a bunch of
older individuals you know we do have a
very divided audience and so I mean I'll
say it I was like f is I hope and I'm
talking to Robin Robin Salon I'm like I
hope F doesn't show up in drag I hope I
hope the Twitter war was fake lo and
behold if I say I'm gonna do something
say I do it um at least you can like
guarantee that about me it was it was it
was funny seeing that like just showing
up there and I was like I was like oh my
God he did it like dressing drag in the
podcast like wow but it was even better
because like my first reaction was oh my
God you showed up in drag so of course f
is now like oh what I'm sorry like was
it not supposed to yeah and then Rob
seeing an opportunity is like you made
him feel bad yeah oh yeah yeah like like
when you when you left like when you
went to go take your makeup on I was
like Benny like you hurt his feelings
yeah now be honest be honest F like did
Benny hurt your
feelings I mean I just I just wanted to
be such a creative person you did not
did
not feelings are
F like the part of it for me that just
sticks in my mind was my internet was
down like before the podcast but I had
already been gotten drags cuz I had
planned to turn up about 30 minutes
early just in case right and so I was
trying to fix my internet in drag s of
in the corner of my house my cat trying
to attack me for like for
attention I'm like go go away baby go
away baby okay fix the internet fix the
internet so now I'm just picturing a
drag queen on the ground like come on
come on come on like I was rewiring
things like this isn't going to work and
then suddenly it started working I don't
know what I did ran in here no F you're
in
drag I mean I like to see that by the
way we should do that again like yeah no
we should actually do the actual show
with you and drag at one point it' be
funny that would be awesome no I think
the other really big Awkward Moment had
to Sammy and and people who stayed in
the post show last week and found out
about that but so I forget how we oh we
found Rob and I found Sammy Comics Bento
sent out a thing oh no was you mea was
it somebody there was a Comics Bento
video that went out and we went to go
check out the thing they asked us to
open the boxes and all that other stuff
so we went to go check out Comics Bento
and they had posted the video of Sammy
opening their box so we clicked it and
we're like hey she's got a great
personality great show she might be you
know we're trying to bring in more of a
female demographics she might be great
to bring on to the show she's got a
great opinion so we decid decided to do
so not really thinking about the age or
anything like that we just invited her
and she showed up on the
show after the first episode like me and
St both kind of assumed that she was 18
like at least 18 or older was the assump
I think there was like
a the we didn't even discuss it it was
more like a hopeful thinking yeah so so
she comes on the first episode
everything goes fine uh and she goes off
and Rob makes the comment of like cuz I
forget why but he was like isn't she
like 15 yeah he's like dude how old is
this well see like like I wasn't I
wasn't on that episode like it was after
the episode aired when you guys had it
on Twitch and I was putting I was
putting on YouTube and like I put like I
was I was watching that and I was like I
mean is is she
like she like like we're a bunch of old
guys I'm like that's like this this
girl's young like she she looks like
she's young and so I was I got in the
chat I was like is she like 15 you guys
cuz like we're going to seem really
weird if we're inviting like old girls
on to the podcast with a bunch of grown
men and um yeah so anyway finish your
story Benny so oh yeah so so he comes in
and says that so now I'm in like pseudo
panic mode like did we assume wrong is
she is she really like an underage kid
and then I'm thinking of the way she
ended because she had plans that night
but I'm like what if her plans were like
go hang out with my mom and dad and like
watch TV or something like like what if
she had to leave cuz what what if her
just a bunch of weirdos what if she
piano recital piano recital going to
ballet yeah
she's so literally it turned into like
almost like a week and a half long
debate of how old is Sammy really and do
we invite her back let's not ask her
directly let's yeah let's not ask her
directly because that would be too
awkward at this point like we've invited
her on no it's better to have like
several meetings about I mean I I
literally like I literally thought about
that like sending her a message like on
Skype or sending her a message on
YouTube or something like or on on a on
Twitter sending M way L creepy for you
to ask how old she is in a public forum
yes how old are you like but yeah I mean
I thought about that I was like okay
Sammy reads yo how old you how old you
be
girl and all your followers just just
jump yeah of course you say I would jump
[__] yeah is this just a reoccurring
thing for all of you wa you get someone
on the show and they're much older than
you think than you think they are cuz I
remember that one of the first things
that was said when I was in like my very
first Skype call of all of you was now
everyone remember f is about 10 years
younger than us and like oh
yeah dude I'm glad you think that but
remember everyone just looks better than
we do yeah exactly we all look old dude
when I first when I first saw you Sammy
story gets better though because and I'm
repeating this for those you guys who
stay post chat but this is for the
actual podcast so so the Sammy story
gets further we start talking to Goldman
uh Goldman Vision he's been doing a lot
of the intros and a lot of the the
moderation for us lately who also like
yeah I'm GNA at least assume he's like
19 but no he's he's much older than that
that's the other thing is that he looks
like he's 12 to
ah I work in school I have no idea how
old anybody is so we're talking talking
to him one day and I forget why we
mentioned it but we like I was talking
to him and I mentioned something about
Sammy or whatever and how I think he
said are you bringing her back and I
said we weren't going to openly invite
her yet because we were debating her age
like we don't know how old she is she
was great on the podcast but if she's
young that could be
weird and he's like what do you mean
she's got a wedding ring she's she's got
to be over 18 at least right and I'm
like thank you thank you so much what I
didn't say at the time was unless it's a
promise
ring I Lu guys you know Sammy did
officially reveal it on the last episode
on the we shouldn't let the cat out of
the bag just let's say that she's over
18 she's don't no dude don't tell people
like it needs to be a guess like it
needs to be a guess like like she she
may or may not be 22 here's the okay
here's your assignment in the chat good
and this is here's your assignment in
the chat this is going to be like she
okay well I mean no to the best of my
knowledge she's not that at all she
might be like 20 she might be 23 she
might be 24 like who knows prob act 65 I
like that here's here's your here's I
don't act like I'm 65 and and you comic
Rod are wrong and everybody who's been
saying I'm 43 in in the chat I'm not 43
I'm 3 I'm not 43 I've been watching I've
been seeing what you guys have been
saying I'm I'm 31 um okay you guys you
guys in the chat like your your
assignment for the next few minutes is
to guess Samy's age and this is this is
going to be like a total catastrophe can
I love how Sam involved in the podcast
but not involved in the podcast at the
same time like we talked about like four
times at this point yeah like it's okay
next thing next thing I think one of the
best moments actually was last episode
puppet Tiffany oh come on that was great
yeah oh you weren't here F Muppet
Tiffany is behind sou it was it was
like it was dude it was it was so crank
anchors like we needed to replace you f
and we discovered that a muppet can do
it yeah
it pulls the face that I pull like well
when you have a muppet like they're firm
so like if you just leave it alone it
looks like they're
like I actually angled her down a little
bit more so she's less dead and more
just like excited I mean it was pretty
entertaining Muppet Tiffany yeah Muppet
Tiffany was a great addition I think she
should become a regular on the podcast
um I'm pretty sure Tiffany doesn't mind
being in a weird puppet position for an
hour and a half no I'm sure that like
the human being who has an opinion
wouldn't rather just display that
opinion through a proxy like a they've
been doing it on Sesame Street for the
last 30 years yeah they're paid to do
that and they're
puppeteers but yeah I like I like Muppet
Tiffany I got her because I used to make
fun of Tiffany like a lot um I love he
just ended it right there I used to mock
I mean like that's turn into something
else but like I that's really what it
was and uh and then one day we went to
the the Muppet whatnot shop at FAO
Schwarz in Manhattan and uh made one and
my plan had originally been to have
maany actually be like a member of the
comic pop like to have her own show and
she was going to like live with us like
it was kind of this weird like Roger
Rabbit world where like the the team and
muppet Tiffany didn't work out no back
back this up just a minute oh you can go
and get your own Muppets made oh yes on
yes when you come here for New York
ComiCon you got to go to FAO Schwarz
make yourself they're called whatnots
because they're the background
characters like you can make and if you
go to FAO schwarz's website you can like
you can design it order it go there pick
it up or you could go to the shop itself
and pick out all the all the pieces you
want they have like a million like noses
and eyes and mths we're doing that
everyone getting a muppet we should each
have a muppet like we need it's like
build a bad but with Muppets yes off by
by the Jon Creature Shop so like these
are real hang on a minute we have we
have a whole family of Puppets no each
Muppet comes with like a little like
hook you put in their in their arms so
like you can move them around like it's
a whole thing oh my God okay how much do
those cost they cost about like between
I think they're around like 90 bucks
okay so we'll do we'll do we'll put out
a Kickstarter for an all Muppet weekly
poll oh my God you have any idea what's
if we get on there and we say hey guys
we're launching a Kickstarter we're
going to raise like
$100,000 mu for a muet okay a guy a guy
raised $40,000 to make potato salad it
would be just my fa and then anything
else just goes into the show okay yes
okay one we need to do that and two we
need to go to the LEGO store because we
didn't do that last time yeah we Muppet
Tiffany's return so while you were gone
basically we had we had Muppet Tiffany
we had Sammy on last week's F yeah yeah
hey F hi my favorite things ever I'm
sorry this is what happened last week I
love F's face he's like a maze like a
child I haven't like I love puppets like
I was in Avenue Q a few years ago and
alls I would do instead of like actually
rehearsing is I would just be backstage
playing with full of puppets
puppet so so I just want to take this
chance to uh say congratulations on a
whole year it's really exciting
yay thanks Mother tiany yeah that's
right anyway so okay
well bye bye muba Tiffany yeah bye guys
I'll see you guys later have a great
show bye like a 5-year-old right now
dude like like she could so be on The
Muppet Show we need to do that we need
okay okay guys here's here's like like
the chat here's your assignment you all
are to go to Twitter and just like spam
The Muppet Show Twitter yeah there's a
new Muppet Show coming out and like get
us on there like that would be so
amazing I can't wait man that show is g
to be tight it's like the office but
with Muppets yes it's going to be
absolutely amazing The Muppets are like
one of my favorite things in the world
it's really really sad that not Muppets
are Muppets are really like awesome I
love Muppets like like when I saw the
Muppet movie the new one like it yeah
that was like a gut punch for me I was
because we hadn't seen Muppets in a long
time like Muppets in Space kind of effed
everything up everything that's what we
did it just messed them all yeah Muppets
was Muppets are awesome I like how s
says stuff s's like like you could end
every phrase that s makes with and
that's all there is to it that's all
there is to it I you you could literally
end everything s says with like and
there's no two ways about it no and eat
me eat me I think I think we've all got
our like our our our conversation like
things like I I like to end a lot of
things like you know what I mean you
know what I mean you guys know I mean
saying righte you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah and like I think Rob's always
go hey how's it going guys what's going
on guys Rob's is usually like here's the
thing I I remember that on on your
interview with nerdsync you open like
he's like and here's Rob from comic like
what's going on guys you open it like it
was your show you're like anyway my show
uh just started
know what my thing is an accent probably
an accent that's I don't think that
counts I don't in America that's all
that you need yeah yeah there are
literally posters all over the London
Underground which like our subway system
um basically saying go to America your
accent is an
aphrodesiac oh dude it is dude man dude
F let me tell you something man I don't
know I don't know what it is
dude what is wrong with you we go
is there a story here no no all right
I'm tell you something man when you come
to New York ComicCon you are get in a
muppet and you are going to get us girl
no no dude no dude all right all right
here's the thing here's the thing
like it's weird like women go nuts over
accents over here like somebody shows up
with an Italian accent and they lose
their minds they show up here with like
I mean somebody could show up here with
like a Swahili accent like an African
accent and well I don't know if that'd
be as sexy but like like a French accent
you know like an English like accents
are like they're exotic so like women
over here so like they love they love
that whole thing but you're I mean
you're gay so I guess whether women
whether not women love your accent
wouldn't really matter to you
so by the way you're gay did you know
that F you're gay just letting you know
reminder I forgot again actually so
we're Americans we like to remind people
even people who aren't gay we like to
tell them they're
G just thinking and then Rob
exploded
right all right so while they're ranting
guys while they're going on I want to
get your opinions what are your favorite
weekly poll moments and I'm going to try
to moderate this because every time we
ask for something 9,000 comments fly up
but it's not okay I I did that like I
when I was doing comics and coffee
somebody made a comment about my voice
and I was like okay I was like how many
of you guys like join my channel because
of my voice and it was just like boom me
I did and it was like like a million
people were like I join because of The
Voice people are still posting comments
now on that video like the voice is that
why I got a bunch of comments the other
day saying I joined this channel cuz of
the
hair okay here they come here they come
here they come I got I got to go like
lightning quick Muppet Tiffany walking
down the stairs for uh F faces
Expressions everything explained is
great The Moth that attacked Rob oh God
I forgot about that the moth The Voice
Rob fading into vapor The Voice this
right now Rob using f as his wingman
smooth his butter voice voice voice
voice Rob exploded Rob's voice haggus
explained your voice is like warm maple
syrup flowing over the body why did you
start that what when Sammy messed up my
favorite is when you guys were musing
over than Thanos being your dad I don't
remember that one but I don't something
silly about s's name change Etc and S
says
okay when Rob attacked the moth so funny
you guys you guys moth was in my house
and I don't know what I'm going to do
dude
dude that moth was was like raising hell
man the D thing was fly Sal as Mo and
Benny just nodding at liking girls with
accents come on man you're married with
the woman of the great accent I do I
never that's true actually that you're
living proof
yeah what can someone please explain to
me Sweden R what um the Sweden I
remember that
one Dr a lot of Co zero on the show guy
in the corner is jacking
it girl in F closet is rubbing it
Benny's opening intros Benny's man like
that that see that is like the staple of
the weekly
pool just the opening intro welcome to
the weekly po remember when I used have
Comics next to me and I would go through
the comics yes and then you were like I
can't even read what this says but trust
me it's
awesome no and it changing with that was
I started reading the comics before the
show the problem was when we did
Thursday I had all the comics but
Tuesday I don't have the comics any
they're all in the in the long box now
that's that's that ended but it used to
be funny cuz they get your week pull
this came out this came out this came
out we're not going to talk about any of
that
yeah
H when you all made Sammy uncomfortable
is that like every time we talk about
Sammy when do we make Sammy
uncomfortable I don't understand when we
make Samm Sammy when did we make
uncomfortable because I know you're
still in the
chat F take a time to like talk quick
they didn't they they shut up um bour
just Beed um I don't
know
I don't know what to
do any is there any other awesome
anecdotes anybody wants to say while I
look for this the the chat picture that
apparently Sammy has picked as the
winner oh Sammy had to go Sammy left a
few what the heck
man that's it she's fired she's she
she's getting the pink slip yeah quick
why don't we why don't you know while
I'm looking for this why don't we have
Tiffany who I know is hiding in the
background say her favorite week P
moment I love that idea but like as as
Tiffany not mu Tiffany don't worry don't
have
uh Hey guys oh it's
real what no I am a puppet don't you
forget it I I personally I think
Tiffany's just as much a member of the
weekly pool as s is but they only have
one camera so yeah it's all it's all we
have we can only get one there's only
one per household that's a rule right
that's what Sal
told Amazon said you can only have one
so you can only have one that's that's I
mean that's true s what are you
saying let's be honest s just took this
opportunity to go to pee so you took the
opportun go pee is that what you said
yeah yeah that's why that's why I'm here
PE so that's probably my favorite moment
is when s had a pee and then I got sit
on here no seriously my favor moment was
honestly getting to meet you guys in
person that was so insane and like it
felt like there was so little planning
up to that point but it still happened
and it was an amazing experience and
like you guys are so true to who you are
on the internet you know what I mean
like you don't have a Persona like what
you present to the internet as who you
are and like I think that that is really
important for growing a community
because they're really attached to who
you are and not who you're pretending to
be so and I'm looking forward to getting
to meet you f yeah realize as weird as
you say you are I'm probably weird I
tone it down for the internet so people
don't go away uh that's okay that's okay
I'm telling you you know Benny and Rob
said that I was really hyper but someone
had to keep up with Benny and uh you and
I did a great job when s and Rob got
tired it was me Tiffany and Danielle
doing like all the interviews and
everything I'm like all right guys well
they're going to sit down Tiffany's got
a lot of energy let's do this yeah
Tiffany was was super hyp okay for those
of you guys in the chat Tiffany's like
like that big around like she's like
this tiny little person and she's like
like that tall
and it's just it's weird are you like
just as Tiny as me then I don't know how
tiny how tall are you I'm I'm 5' four
and I have a 17inch waist okay oh my God
man you are like a dart you're tiny I'm
I'm 5' seven oh my God taller than
somebody 57 isn't tiny who was that o of
these guys it is 57 ain't tiny that's
I'm 6'1 Rob is 6 like two and Sal is
like 69 s's like8 foot tall are you
kidding me that's tall enough to be a
female catwalk model that is not
sure like you heard your first Tiffany
you have to become a catwalk model
that's yeah
no okay I when you said Tiny I was
expecting like British YouTuber tiny cuz
every British YouTuber I meet is my
height or smaller wow I'm like 4 foot
eight you know it's stopped for me at
one point so no see people are posting
up their height in the
chat what is with you people everybody's
like here's how I actually no Rob you're
six feet right like we're like right
about the same part I'm like 5'11
something like that 6 foot okay I I was
a little taller than you yeah yeah
you're taller than me yeah I was the
shortest person there with the exception
of Tiffany so I remember Rob being
closest to my height of the guys other
than Ethan well Dave was pretty short
too oh yeah Dave was there for one Sammy
is 78 now that she's not there without a
defend herself but
that's
true people are like f how do you
explain get to work all right so I think
before we announce the winner of the
contest and we start bringing this to a
close with with Tiffany here yeah Rob
it's time to explain haggus do it I
haven't done enough re okay so so once
upon a time like there was there was
some crazy [__] in Scotland and he
was like Hey guys like let's see what
happens if we just take like this stupid
combination of stuff let's just take
like a sheep's stomach and let's just
like cram it with like as much stuff as
we can without it like rupturing and
blowing up and we're going to use the
contents of the sheep itself to do it
because it's like more
economic and so like all the other
Scotland people were like that's an
awesome idea because we're drunk and so
and so this person this person in
Scotland F you are not going to
interrupt my
story and so this Scottish person took
like this sheep's stomach and like
cramped full of stuff and then put it
into like what passes for an oven in
Scotland because they don't have
electricity and they uh that's actually
candle light candle fedro he's he's he's
powering he's powering his computer on
like leprechaun magic so it's my cat on
like a hamster wheel it's like on a
hamster wheel so so this is what happens
when you have ADD like nothing gets
finished so anyway so he put it put it
in the oven and and cooked it and uh it
came out of the oven and people were
just like like this is amazing like this
tastes so good because we're drunk and
everything tastes good when you're drunk
and so like like I mean like literally
like I've been drunk like everything
tastes good when you're drunk and
um Waffle House tastes good so and
Waffle House never tastes good so
um yeah so people were like wow this is
that sponsor by the way I was working on
a deal with Waffle House oh no we lost
Waffle House oh what we going to do they
all like 3:00 a.m. drunks so AR going to
come to our Channel
anymore but um but yeah so so like
people ate it and they were like this is
really good and then it like stuck
around you know yeah how accurate is
that fast no tell it's it's like 100%
accurate I mean you lost it when you
said Scotland cuz haggus is actually
originally from Northwest England it's
just really popular in Scotland well see
now you're just now you're like
splitting hairs is all you're doing
they're like different countries I know
they're
like especially we don't know we don't
know about that F we don't know England
I think the UK is just one giant thing
in the Soviet Union still I I'm pretty
sure everything's just won there's
there's all like all there is is like
the USSR there's and that's the yeah
USSR they just read everything at this
point my favorite thing about the UK is
you know in The Animaniacs there was
that song that sang all the nations of
the world yep um if it got Wales oh did
they yeah Wales is not on there and it
was like that perfectly disg how
everyone in the UK feels about Wales
it's just England it's it's just
England actually here's here's a fun
fact you guys may not have known did you
guys know that like true I mean this is
true too that ribs um were discovered by
accident okay but then how was the MC
rib discovered the mick Rib was
discovered because somebody said here's
a really good way to take meat that we
can pass off his ribs and put barbecue
sauce on it and then like a bunch of
people who were high were like this is
amazing B claim there to call that meat
all right on that I said I said what
passes for meat oh okay hold on if you
guys don't know this one but Tiffany
remembers this one the one thing we've
never mentioned that happened in the New
York Comic Con trip was the time that I
almost murdered Rob in the car because
he was irritated without his vape and he
was trying to convince me that the MC
rib counted as ribs and if s wanted ribs
we needed to go to McDonald's because
the true MC Rib was back and I got in
like a full I didn't realize he was
trolling me and I got into aown argument
about why the MC rib is not food dude I
was I was so messing around with we're
in a Honda Pilot there's three seats
like rows of seats and like you have
them separated by seats I'm all the way
in the back trying desperately to find a
place where we can get robed some Vape
because he's freaking out oh dude and
and and like and we're also debating
where to get food and at this time it's
like what like 9 o' so everything's at
closing so we're debating where we can
go yeah some someone has suggested that
that we should go get barbecue at like
the barbecue place and so and Rob was
like I could totally go for a MC rib and
I was like and I was like Rob MC rib is
not barbecue and he's like what do you
mean it's called the MC rib it's got rib
in it it's a like Rob the MC rib does
not have any rib meat it's it's like
everything that isn't a rib meat like no
man it's the MC rib it is is the
greatest rib ever it's got no bones
which makes it even
better I finally got Tru get out in the
car I'm like Rob like I got my phone out
I'm like looking up the recipe for the
Nick rib like there's no there's no rib
meat Rob it's like chicken and pork and
like Hooves and like there's no rib meat
in this thing dude you went the mile to
prove me wrong heang I I mentioned this
in the comments I thought you were going
to talk about when we went to get Ramen
and you ordered the spiciest thing on
the menu oh dude okay hold on I'm GNA
let me tell this story let me tell the
story let me tell the story okay guys so
so we're at New York ComicCon and and
we're we're like where do we where
should we go for lunch because like the
day before we went to that Italian joint
which had like the best chicken parmesan
sandwiches ever and so um so so uh
Tiffany and sa were like there's this
really good place this really good
Japanese joint that sells like
legitimate ramen noodle like real Ramen
food and so we're like okay so we get in
there and uh and we all sit down and
order like I just get like this regular
noodle plate which you can see on my
Instagram and
um Everybody
ERS everybody orders their normal food
and uh and Benny's like like what's this
and the chick's like like it's spicy
it's spicy and Benny is like he's like I
like spicy food so he he like literally
orders the the absolute hottest thing
they like the HT this is this is like
this is like the Buffalo Wild Wings
blazing wing challenge is what Benny did
at this Japanese ramen Place yep and so
the food like the the noodles get there
and Benny's Benny's like yes you know I
can't wait to try this and so bny like
takes his takes his stuff in there and
like starts to eat it and within like
like seconds like the face is getting
red and the sweat's coming out and
Benny's like dying over here but he's
like I'm going to finish this I'm going
to finish this well the best part about
that was is that was technically our
first weekly pool business meeting so
like so like I'm sitting going like
here's here's what we're probably GNA I
think we should go in this direction I
think we should start working on a
website I think we should start doing
this stuff and so I'm sitting there and
I'm
like okay so so Tiffany you can do the
website right you like okay why am I
still eating this all right so s we're
going to run this part of it we're going
to do this oh my God okay okay so how
are we going to handle social
media it was amazing the early moments
where I started to question a couple of
things like is he just talking out of
insanity because like I have a feeling
he's talking out of insanity right now y
don't worry F this year when we go to
New York Comic County you will be
experiencing all of this wonderfulness
that's right all this it's just like
standard convention experience it's fine
oh it's it's it's fine until you
experience it with Vinny let me tell you
something yeah quite like going to a
convention with Benny I got to tell you
what the hell Benny like dud we got in
there we got in there on the first day
and this this is like I was Benny was
running people ragged he was like all
right we got on in the first day like
all right guys let's just like take some
time let's poke around let's have some
fun you know investigate stuff and see
what all they have and we're like cool
you know it was like a really cool
Friday it was a relaxing day we get in
there Saturday 0 to 60 from the time we
get in there all right we need to go
these guys and these guys and it was
exclusives and interviews and I mean we
went we went to Indie alley we did all
that St
okay that's totally different from my
current convention experience which is
wake up at 5:00 in the morning get in
Cosplay for 900 in the morning go around
find photographers and be like can you
do a photo shoot with me please okay
thanks that would be great it's my
business card and do photo shoots all
day well now you'll have us to do that
for you we'll run around and we'll get
people take photos of you I mean for the
record Tiffany loves taking pictures so
she'll just follow you around with the
camera just yeah and I I'll go I'll just
I'll just bully people into taking
photos of you like we're at the
convention Rob tired s's tired I'm
trying to get an interview and I'm like
we really need to get like show floor
footage and like 2 seconds later
Tiffany's like boom look what I got I
got all everything you needed this is
all you want it right like I get it all
I'm like holy crap that's my job dude
Tiffany you were magic with that camera
like some of that footage you got was
unbelievable the weird part about it is
because Tiffany's Tiffany's female and
because Tiffany's short uh basically you
wouldn't even know Tiffany's there and
you'll just see a camera
like oh I remember all of us standing
back at the Marvel announcement I'm like
we can't get close enough to get footage
for this if we wanted to use it how are
we going to use it and Jeff's like don't
worry about it give me the camera and
like within like seconds you just see
the camera pop up next to the stage like
nothing nothing like a periscope just
watching it all like cuz she's so short
she's holding it over her head like
this I mean really love do what look one
of my favorite things just because it's
so funny is really tiny people but with
giant cameras with huge
lenses I really should probably just get
the biggest camera I should rent the
biggest camera they have with the
biggest lens oh yeah we should we should
go out and
buy machine exactly yeah like we should
go get like one of those like $144,000
like studio quality H like 4K cameras
we'll just get we'll run an IMAX camera
we'll shoot the whole con and IMAX
what's that 4K 3D one the ones they use
for Avatar oh God yeah that's that's
money in the dresser drawer man I don't
know what you're talking
about one of the black magic cameras
with the wireless lenses that you can
just carry around s's taking too long
apparently s is now jacking it no s's
over here he's he's at high station s
are you jacking it no I'm not jacking
it saw that comic R you son of a
[__] would you like your seat back yeah
I'm coming back all right guys I'm gonna
give I'm gonna I'm gonna give up the The
Throne of comic pop to S here so but no
seriously congratulations on a year it's
awesome thank you congratulations to you
too you're a part of this yeah that's
right I was I was just waiting to see if
you were going to say anything yeah I
was wondering but you know it's cool
although we might replace you with
Muppet Tiffany I'm sorry I know I know I
know I get it though I understand whoa
you made you made the yeah that that
exposure got crazy when s got in there I
know s made like a solar flare happen
over getting the hell out of here later
s came in in a full black T-shirt like
the like the camera's like oh there
Tiffany's white now she's whiter exactly
did you change shirts no it's same shirt
we came back in like a totally different
outfit yeah facial hair shape I
considered coming back as Alan Moore but
I was like all right do the elen more
impression for people who haven't heard
it you haven't done it once this episode
yeah I built a magic cave in my
basement that's good enough I guess
that's warrell story Warren ell tells
amazing story about how like Alan Mo
will just leave voicemails on his on his
machine he's like I can't sell my
house cuz cuz not everyone wants a magic
cave before I think I think we've we've
ranted and raved enough about this last
year and I think is to pretty much close
out on this whole thing I just thank you
to everyone I mean it's it's all because
of you guys that we here I mean you guys
can enjoy the content all you want but
it wouldn't matter if nobody was here F
would never have contacted us if people
weren't watching so h no why would
he it's sad to say but it's true I W
blame you man
so and here's to another great year
maybe we'll hit 52 episodes this year I
doubt it but W hopefully yeah I don't
know this is is this the 40th or the
39th episode whichis the 39th I think
maybe the 40th I if we have the weekly
pool west or east whatever we want to
call
them episodes the great lak Great Lakes
weekly pool yeah for the record though
guys don't forget we do have a weekly
pull Facebook it's facebook.com thee
weekly pull we also have the weekly poll
Twitter which is uh at the at the weekly
poll right that's Y and you can stay up
to date on all of our content plus
whatever happens with the weekly poll
and don't forget I have an Instagram
comic
storan I also have an Instagram comicpop
official I have an Instagram too it's
rvn fast yeah and I have a weekly pool
or I have a uh Instagram that's called I
am not Rob is it really yeah it's called
I am not Rob yeah I fig I fig we all
throw that in there since Rob threw that
in there
but
but other than that guys um I mean we
stick around for the Post shell like
usual I got a few questions I want to
ask this community to see if you guys
are game for what you want that kind of
a thing but we're going to close out the
show portion so Rob has not a 4our
upload and that's it guys thank you guys
so much and stick around we aren't
actually leaving this is we we upload
this and this is the part that stays
there don't forget if you are watching
this post this was recorded at
twitch.tv/ eligible monster where you
can see pre-shows and post shows of us
just ranting and raving half the time f
is naked yep and and from time to time
you will get a chance to see oh
wow I'm too sexy for my shirt too sexy
for my shirt it won't go further than
that ever but um but periodically you
guys will get a chance to see me Benny
and possibly somebody else jumping in to
uh wow somebody's heard he started holy
[__] the instag the Instagram's blowing
up are they yeah it it's blowing up man
it's nuts but uh guys will get a chance
to see um to to hang out with me and
Benny and possibly a third person while
we're playing like video games so like
GTA and stuff like that so yeah not all
the time every once in a while the last
thing that I want to do guys is we are
going to announce our
winner but I've messed up everything and
I can't show the image apparently
so but you want us to get it like I'm
working on it hold on I'm trying to
figure out a way to get it on the screen
whoa what happened while we wait 90s
theme music 90s music what happened 90s
90s music what is your wo we're good
what we're good
okay we recommended F get naked
Tiffany's getting naked you're just like
oh my God no are we are we finished are
we finished with the regular episode not
yet I'm we got announce the winner I'm
trying to find it I did download it I
thought I had this all prepped up but
that panel's not working on our stream
so I'm trying to find it now so chosen
by Sammy Reids so you guys can all argue
with
her the chat which is not in a weird
spot on the thing cuz I can't get it to
work
[Laughter]
right the the the chat the the chat hold
on I'm working on it guys this was going
really well this was going really well
you know oh yeah this was pretty awesome
yeah I've actually got that as my
desktop yeah thank you very much for
theen that's cool all right here we go
the chat I got it now boom it's really
small I'll fix that the chat there we go
it's officially broadcast on the
thing it's black I know it's black
thanks I know thanks everybody what
would I do without you this is why
you're a villain this is why you're a
villain there we go that is the winner
of the chat and that person
is Dave ID
really Dave the chat it was Dave shot
shoot myself and the weekly pull a tweet
we'll work out you getting your prize
thank you guys so much for the winner uh
and on that note we're ending the
official podcast so that we can move
back over to just chatting with you like
we always do and I'll get rid of that so
it's not broken up there we go boom yep
so that's it guys that is the official
winner chosen by Samy re if you disagree
with it tweet her and be like I disagree
but you're awesome anyway do that
please and uh yeah so make sure you guys
stick around for the uh for the Post
show and uh yeah oh what does everybody
have going on this
week questions I'm doing a bunch of
Batman is a game coming out if you
weren't aware yeah I I did a bunch of
Avengers last month so this month it's
bunch of Batman this month is history
video month for me so I'm putting out
four history videos every week someone
kill me
yep nice uh this week back issues gonna
be about Jos weeden's the astonishing
X-Men oh
God yeah and tonight uh we'll be
releasing week two of the tians for
Secret Wars on Secret Wars
tldr wait week
two conver I'm like three or whatever of
Secret Wars but it's the second week of
tie-ins we only read the tie-ins on that
show see I consider like like the way
I'm doing Secret Wars like they gave us
like it was like a taster I think like
an appetizer with like week one so like
week two officially started like like
I'm sorry week one like Secret Wars
officially started with like all the
tians when all that stuff came out like
that's why I consider that week one well
this is the second wave of tiin yeah
awesome and yeah I'm sorry I have um Age
of Apocalypse should be finished by the
end of this week fingers crossed um it
doesn't matter what you have and then uh
and then next week I think we're just
going to start going with the trend of
what they're doing with secret War so I
know they just release Inferno yeah it's
garbage it's I got to rescue my sister
some's going to spend years and years
and years running into the Citadel only
to find out that ilana's really just
giving into her demon H yeah it's
horrible oh I I forgot to mention I'm
vlogging now on a channel called it's
not very effective because I'm really
creative with Channel names I like how
you maintain that theme is rather
effective it's super effective it's not
very effective that is that's actually a
really awesome name it's not very
effective yeah yeah especially for a
vlogging Channel where I literally just
do comedy
videos that'll be com related sometimes
hold we got to close out the show itself
so don't forget I am comic story and
that is Comics explain that is Comic pop
and that is super effective thank you
guys for a year and years to another
year so that is the official close out
um Rob when doing this post you got you
got to drown that part out